[موسيقى]
التضخم هو ظاهره
اقتصاديه مزمنه موجوده دائما في الاتصال
في الاقتصاد المحلي الاقتصاد العالمي لكن
باختصار شديد التضخم هو الارتفاع في اسعار
السلع والخدمات خلال فتره زمنيه محدده هذا
هو باختصار شديد المقصود من التدخل
[موسيقى]
هم يحدث التضخم عندما اولا سواء انه الطلب
يزداد بشكل كبير جدا او انه العرض المعروض
من السلع والخدمات ايضا يكون اقل بكثير من
الطلب وكذلك عند زياده الانفاق الحكومي
زياده تكاليف الانتاج او زياده المعروض من
النقود في السوق كل هذه العوامل تؤدي الى
ارتفاع
الاسعار بشكل عام ايضا من الاسباب التي
تؤدي الى ظاهره التضخم الاضطرابات
السياسيه والاضطرابات الاجتماعيه وايضا
حتى الامراض لاحظنا عندما جاءت جائحه
كورونا اوقفت الانتاج بشكل كبير جدا وعطلت
الامدادات وبالتالي كل هذا ادى الى ارتفاع
الاسعار عالميه للحروب ازمه اوكرانيا وحرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا ايضا ادت الى قفزه
كبيره جدا في الاسعار فهنالك عوامل كثيره
متعدده احيانا اقتصاديه احيانا سياسيه
جاستراتيجيه تؤ دي الى تفاقم الظاهره
ظاهره
[موسيقى]
ارتفاع الاسعار المواد الاساسيه تحديدا
النقل التعليم الصحه الطاقه كل هذه تؤدي
الى ارتفاع
الاسعار في المواد الاساسيه في السلع
الاساسيه والخدمات الاساسيه وهو ما يضعف
القدره الشرائيه للافراد وبالتالي تصبح
قدرتهم على تربيه الاحتياجات الاساسيه اقل
مما كانت عليه في السنه
[موسيقى]
نعم التضخم يؤثر في سعر صرف العمله فعندما
يزداد التضخم تفقد العمله جزء من قيمتها
الحقيقيه مقارنه بالعملات الاخرى اي عندما
يرتفع التضخم تصبح القدره الشرائيه
للافراد
اقل وهذا ما يؤدي الى اضعاف جاذبيه هذه
العمله بالنسبه للمستثمرين وفي الاسواق
بشكل عام وهو ما يؤدي الى انخفاض عمله هذا
البلد